sono nata a napoli e da quando ero
piccola ho sempre disegnato mio padre
faceva il grafico pubblicitario e lascio
il mio fratello liberi di disegnare su
tutte le pareti di casa
questo mi ha trasmesso una grande
libertà di fare pensare ciò che più
desideravo da piccolo avevo bisogno
desideravo avevo desiderio di conoscenza
desiderio di capire la realtà che mi
circondava il desiderio di farlo
attraverso il disegno un mezzo che
continua e destra che era e continua ad
essere per me il disegno io fin da
piccolo ho letto tanti fumetti fumetti
d'amore fumetti d'avventura fumetti
storici e fumetti che mi hanno insegnato
soprattutto i sentimenti che hanno
contribuito a formare il mio vero e
proprio bagaglio emotivo e sentimentale
però crescendo mancava qualcosa quando
sono diventata inequivocabilmente
signorina non ho trovato nessun fumetto
che mi spiegasse effettivamente cosa mi
stava succedendo
ricevevo molte informazioni e per lo più
confuse tipo io leggo è voi leggete mi
raccomando ora non ti devi appoggiare in
bagno tutte le donne cioè le hanno e
doloroso ti fanno male le tette soffre
tantissimo ora ti devi stare più accorta
non c'è più una bambina fai attenzione
agli uomini che altrimenti esce incinta
estingue la vita tua
devi stare a riposo è come se fossi
malata non può uscire non puoi farti il
bagno e neanche la doccia solo per
cinque giorni al mese
poi passa ok è praticamente per me il
fumetto è sempre stato uno strumento di
conoscenza quindi desideravo tramandare
questa conoscenza attraverso il mezzo
che poi ho deciso di utilizzare e far
comprendere a
a tramandare questa conoscenza le
bambine ragazze e donne un aspetto così
naturale della vita come quello della
sessualità e dell'affettività
ok facendolo però disegnando questo
fumetto
ho riscontrato due sentimenti ovvero la
paura perché fino allora nessuno aveva
ancora affrontato un argomento ancora
coperto da una fitta coltre di tabù come
le misurazioni e la riconoscenza perché
finalmente qualcuno l'affrontava in
maniera schietta cruda ma dedicata al
tempo stesso non contenta di questa
sfida
ho voluto affrontare un'altra sfida
raccontare un altro mondo anche questo
coperto da un bel po di tabù nonostante
faccia parte della nostra quotidianità
ovvero il mondo delle app online delle
app di dating che permettono alla
conoscenza di persone sconosciute e
persone sconosciute chi nel 68 sognava
l'amore libero non l'avrebbe mai
immaginato che sarebbe stato
accontentato da un cellulare da tutti i
mezzi che noi adesso siamo a
disposizione dai nostri smartphone
questo ha reso le comunicazioni con gli
sconosciuti molto più facili ma non per
questo ha reso la vita effettivamente
più semplice queste app riducono al
minimo le dinamiche dell'approccio e
della seduzione ma se da un lato
oscurano mettono in ombra la parte
dell'affettività dall'altro necessitano
dell'equipaggiamento giusto per poter
affrontare tutto quello a cui ci pongono
e ci mettono davanti alle nostre
difficoltà noi stessi per fare questo ho
disegnato questo fumetto e volevo volevo
raccontare come
le app fondamentalmente cambiassero la
vita di tutti noi
ho cercato di raccontare come il sesso
non deve essere ostaggio del senso di
colpa né di inadeguatezza
ma che poi deve trasformarsi nel più
sincero strumento di consapevolezza e di
conoscenza di se stessi anche attraverso
gli altri dobbiamo imparare però a
essere anche coraggiosi e e a renderci
consapevoli degli strumenti che
utilizziamo noi siamo pronti a fare
questo perché siamo liberi ma siamo più
liberi se siamo consapevoli
grazie